good evening i'm matthew spaulding
associate vice president dean of
educational programs for hillsdale
college here in washington dc
welcome to the allen p kirby center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
hillsdale east as we like to call it and
i'm very pleased this evening to welcome
a good friend
of mine and of the college
our students have left for the semester
although i'm currently grading their
exams
and the summer students haven't arrived
yet so you'll have to settle with my
introduction victor
i'm especially pleased to to to have him
here
for two reasons one is as a
as a college
we have
proudly continued to teach
uh things like the classics
uh and our speaker this evening is a
great scholar of the classics
uh someone whose books uh i hope all of
us have enjoyed
uh but also it'll as you'll hear here in
a moment we have we share some common
roots in terms of where we grew up
victor davis hansen is a senior fellow
at the hoover institution and a
professor of classics emeritus at
california state university fresno
he's also very happy that we have to say
the wayne and marcia busk distinguished
fellow in history at hillsdale college
he received his ba in classics the
university of california santa cruz was
a fellow at the american school of
classical studies in athens and received
his phd in classics from stanford
university
he is from california
indeed
he was the fifth successful generation
to live in the same house on his family
farm in selma california
which is in the central valley of
california which is about 45 40 minutes
north of where i grew up in a little
town called corcoran
and
that
fact explains a lot of his understanding
and his shaping of how he thinks about
many things as we'll see
he was a full-time orchard and vineyard
grower
right after he got his phd so i'm glad
to see that he put it to good use
before he went to csu fresno campus to
initiate their classics language program
um in 2000 he was awarded the national
humanities medal in 2008 he won the
bradley prize
he's a weekly columnist for national
review online as well as the tribune
media services
he's published several journals
newspapers magazines
he's actually one of those people i
oftentimes look down upon detached and
jealous of he's written 23 books
um including wars of the ancient greeks
in a war like no other however how the
athenians and spartans fought the
peloponnesian war
his most recent work will be released in
october the second world wars how the
first global conflict was fought and won
as the distinguished followed history at
hillsdale he regularly teaches our
students on campus
about military history and classical
culture
he also teaches in our online courses if
you're interested
which are all free at hillsdale.edu and
he's was involved in our course on
athens and sparta which came out last
spring and he taught sessions on life in
government in athens
athens and the persian war and athens in
the peloponnesian war
he's recently writing about
current election what's gone in the
united states donald trump and trumpism
foreign policy challenges questions of
immigration
his talk this evening is entitled taking
stock of trumpism where it came from
what is accomplished and where it is
going
please join me in welcoming our guest
this evening victor davis hanson
[Music]
[Applause]
there's only five thousand classes in
the united states so it's a very small
group i mentioned that because uh i got
a letter yesterday
a very angry classicist and he said
you've become the enoch powell of
classics
and you haven't done anything good to
you wrote that one good article on the
use of numbers in thucydides seventh
book ever since then it's all be it's
all been downhill and you'll regret it
on your deathbed
that's the cloud reminding what
churchill said about classicist
they know little latin and less greek
and yet they're supposed to be experts
on it but i've had a rocky relationship
in the world of classical languages i
thought i would just speak for about 30
minutes on
the phenomenon of trumpism where he came
from how he got elected what he's trying
to do and what the future holds
all of you
have come across that phenomena or maybe
you participated in
when you had to look both ways when
somebody asked you if you voted for
trump or you always said this phrase
this is my favorite well he wasn't my
first choice
or after the primary
i don't agree with everything he does
but i you hear that a lot it's always
the same
well
hillary clinton the other day gave an
interview and or actually she gave a
speech to a woman's international group
when she said she was robbed of the
election she's like typical hillary i
take full responsibility but
i was robbed because uh i'm a woman of
course
and of course james comey stole the
election you think that they'd be mad
that he's uh that he was still there
rather than mad that he was fired
yesterday but nevertheless and then of
course the russians did it
as i said to a group today the russians
did it as sort of like
gurim going to hitler in august 1941 and
said well we could have taken moscow but
it was very cold
and
milthuen said it's not like we're a
tropical people
in the german military handbook it said
how to prepare for snow but they were
they were blaming everything on the snow
as if the red army didn't have a role in
their defeat outside moscow that was
what hillary i mean
that's what russians do they try to
interfere with elections they didn't put
a gun to her head and say you know have
a
home brew server or
you know sell one quarter
approve the sale of one quarter of
uranium holdings of north america
but she's still angry and what lost her
of course that election and empowered
trump was that she was
shrill snarky she wasn't a good
candidate
and she wasn't
she when she
uh told the truth
she was less believable than when trump
told a lie
and
she was a year younger than trump and
physically
she was 10 years older than trump and
trump
violated all the rules of personal
fitness he looked too heavy
i had a friend that met him and i said
what was it like and he said i got a
choice between
mcdonald's big mac and uh burger king
and he said then for dessert it was
haagen-dazs out of the cup so hillary
ate right and she did everything right
and that she was less healthy than
somebody who was older and had that
animal cunning and animal energy
so she wasn't a strong candidate
she
had no message other than i'm a woman
and i'm not donald trump the monster
and then
the only key to her election is that she
was going to win
only one way you knew it we all knew it
that barack obama had bequeathed a
suicide pact
i should say it's a wrong metaphor he'd
signed a suicide pact with the
democratic party
because basically he said i'm going to
go down the community organizing
identity politics
reverend wright road once i'm elected
and i'm going to get empower
uh identity politics minority groups to
come out in unheard of numbers
and vote in mass at levels that you
can't imagine 92 percent
and
well as whereas the klinger vote or what
we now know is the irredeemables and
deplorables will fall off i will so
appeal to the other groups that it won't
matter and of course it was true
but the problem was it was transferable
to nobody other than barack obama
so hillary inherited all the down sign
and none of the upside
and when obama was through with that
carnage he had ruined the democratic
party
and they had lost local elections
governorships
state legislature senate house but
generation of the supreme court probably
and the presidency
and yet she doubled down on that
she called one quarter of the united
states you know basically irredeemable
when she said half his supporters were
such
and you thought if she was smart
she would reprise that annie oakley role
was pretty effective in 2008 remember
she said that she shot guns with her dad
she had boiler makers she boil bold but
then you start to realize that by 2016
it was a different party obama had
destroyed that bill clinton party that
aw shucks good old boy it didn't exist
anymore and she would inherit a paradigm
that would only work for obama
and i i think i wrote an article saying
you know where this is going to lead
it's going to lead to
very lucrative speaking engagements for
obama as a reward for destroying his own
party he's going to be loved and she's
going to be hated for trying to imitate
a losing
something that has to be losing and
that's exactly why she lost the election
and then of course
the other reason was that we all thought
donald trump had had a say in it we all
thought that
february march donald trump was the only
candidate that could lose to hillary
clinton remember that
and by everybody said well a lot of them
did
you know rubio's the ideal candidate or
walker he's so
we had good governors jindal
christie walker we had senators rand
paul and
we had jeb bush it had the dynasty the
money the name we had outsiders that
were more
versed in facts like
fiorina
and uh ben carson nobody thought trump
had these particular gifts but now
looking back i think most of you agree
he might have been the only candidate
that could have won
because unlike john mccain he was not
going to put reverend wright off that
type i'm not going to mention reverend
wright
and like unlike mitt romney
he wasn't going to apologize for his
station in life you can imagine if trump
had run in 2008
reverend wright would have been 24 7 all
the time and had he been mitt romney in
2012 when candy crawley hijacked the
he would have jumped over and grabbed
the mic
so at least he was the first person who
in lee out water stuff remember lee
outwater he gave us the boston harbor uh
tank
and willie horton ads
and turned a patrician aristocratic
snarky george h.w bush into somebody who
you know ate corn nuts and was one of us
and it was very effective and after he
died bush lost we hadn't seen that type
of guerrilla fighting until trump came
and so he
whatever it was going to happen he was
going to take for once in all the fight
to hillary in a very
mean spirited but necessary way
and that's why he would resonate in a
way that she couldn't imagine
and he also understood a couple of
things we've all been told that
demography is destiny but is it really
in the electoral college
who cares who wins a popular vote if
certain states are more important than
others a vote in iowa is worth a lot
more
ohio or wisconsin a lot more than my
vote in california at least on the
national level
and trump seemed to
i remember
watching cnn when somebody said
i think they were talking about jorge
ramos you see he seems to be oblivious
to the ramifications of the latino vote
i said yeah he is
because most of the latino vote and i'm
leaving somewhere that's 90 percent
mexican-american was going to go in two
states california that was never going
to go red and texas that was never going
to go blue
and the states that it probably had
turned maybe colorado and new mexico
were going to be turned no matter who
now if he had made the argument there's
a half a million latinos who hate trump
in ohio and michigan and wisconsin i
would have listened to it but the point
i'm making is that he looked at the
electoral college
and
he understood that
demography is destiny as it applies to
particular states and not the popular
vote
and then when you add one final
element to the election that
trump campaigned as if he was going to
lose and he was desperate and hillary
campaign as if she was already won it
was a classic hair in the tortoise and
so she was down in places like
georgia and arizona that were never
going to go red at least in our
generation thinking that i'm going to
get a mandate while not visiting
wisconsin once
and he had a certain touch they made it
a strategic error the clintons did by
thinking
he is a billionaire therefore he can't
be a populist you can be a populist and
be a trillionaire and you can be dead
broke and be an elitist
and she's proved that very well she and
her husband and so are the obamas
and so when he had that queen's accent
and he surrounded himself with the likes
of mike tyson world wrestling federation
people
people in these key electoral states
that i've got somebody like donald trump
in my family
and i bring him out every once in a
while
i like him but i don't want to be seen
but they understood who he was and that
queen's accent worked to his advantage
and i'm being very cynical i don't want
to be snarky myself because
i talked to a new york developer once
and he called me and said you know
i watch from my tower he has a big
high-rise i shouldn't say high-rise i
guess it's a skyscraper and he said i
see donald trump
and it is true that he deviates from his
planned walk when he gets out of his lim
and he goes and talks to cement people
and i see people clapping that are on
construction sites so whatever he is
it's genuine that people like him and i
thought about that when hillary was
telling the coal miners they had to
learn how to build solar panels
he was using the first person plural
pronoun hour did you notice i've never
heard a candidate in history say our
miners our farmers our soldiers nobody
told him to do that and then when you
threw kelly conway and steve bannon into
the mix
these are people that look like they've
been around the block and robbie mook
and all those guys that for clinton
looked like they came right out of
dupont circle upper west side so it was
sort of the metrosexuals against the
guys that had been around too long
and
i had met and i've been very over the
years i've met
infrequently but on occasion steve
bannon so i as i was saying to my wife
she goes who is that guy and she said
that
you can't always get what you want
started playing at a right-wing trump
rally and i said that is steve bannon
so there were elements that explain why
trump won i want to add if i could just
a little excursive
there was also
a deep-seated anger emotional in america
that can't really be articulated well
because it's it's an emotional gut felt
and i guess they could summarize it
where there's a lot of people in the
united states
the
the elite on the two coastal strips
uh you know say that they're
irredeemable or deplorable or we say
they're not knowledge-based or
post-industrial whatever they're not in
with it
they're not but they are very angry at
people who don't live by the
ramifications of their own ideology
and by that i mean
uh if i'm in california and i'm told we
have to have high-speed rail it's going
to be built where i live near hanford
and not in palo alto where it should
start
if i'm told we have to pay the highest
electricity electricity rates from the
country it's not going to be
in palo alto where the temperature i i
have an office at stanford i've never
turned on the heat or the or the cooling
if i go in august 15th
when it's 107 in fresno walmart is full
of hispanic people who are there for the
air conditioning they sit there all day
as if their kids it's a play playground
and so people
if i hear a lecture from colleagues at
stanford and tell me that open borders
are a great thing i know that they put
their kids in castelia or hark or the
menlo school they don't put them in the
selma public schools
and there was a sense of anger
when i get up in the morning i don't get
a letter and say mr hansen your column
from tribute media services was
outsourced to somebody from south korea
he can do it at half the
price it just doesn't occur to me that
occurs to a lot of people
and that was epitomizing this clinton
couple
that
talked one way and lived the other
progressive progressive progressive and
then they had a crime basically a crime
syndicate and they had taste and
appetites
that were entirely hypocritical and did
not you couldn't square the circle of
what they said and how they lived and
that was apparent to people that the
democratic party had become
a party of the elite and a party of the
poor and had not just
dissent or on interest in the middle but
actual contempt for them
and that was fatal for them in these
states i would say that you can see that
the obamas are very much like the
clintons
so i don't think obama will be the
avatar of a of a movement
think about it take take those four
people bill and hillary michelle and
barack
they're the only
post-presidential couples that went back
in our era to washington carter didn't
reagan didn't the bushes didn't they
both bought mansions they both organized
political action groups they all both
with a wink and nod said my wife may be
still politically active someday
therefore you should
donate to check the library check the
foundation check the 400 000 speaking
engagements
uh they both looked at marriage not
maybe as an act of love so much as a
business proposition
they both had complaints about how life
had not treated them well and how they
deserve more money or more
influence or power and people looked at
clinton i think
the obama that was really a bad image
for the democratic party this people can
take a lot of things but they don't like
to be treated like idiots and to the
idea that these are people in the
trenches or they're good old boys or
they're hard-working progressives or you
didn't build that it's not time to
profit or at some point you need enough
money and then go make four hundred
thousand dollars it just doesn't work
and so
i think that's something to think about
as far as trump himself so he's elected
and how are we going to characterize the
first hundred days
part of the problem with the media
hysteria is again
if you've lost the legislatures the
local offices governorship senate house
then you don't have political power
and so
there's an anger at that and it's if
you're if you're the party of the very
wealthy the suburban and the educated
which now the democratic party is if you
look at the per capita income of blue
counties
overwhelmingly
these are democratic then you're angry
that stupider people
less well-spoken people less educated
are dictating decisions that you think
affect your lives and you don't know how
to respond because politically there's
no outlet for it
and one of the ironies is the media now
is the other party
so if the media starts to use the f word
or the [ __ ] word or whatever that then
the politicians follow suit not vice
versa if the media builds up black lives
matter or transgendered hollywood
celebrities create lgbt movement or
global warming comes out of the culture
then the democratic party reacts to it
so it's this hysteria from trump
is in the democratic since reactive
chuck schumer reacts to trump after what
he reads in the media about trump
and they don't really have a political
base because
dianne feinstein is 83
nancy pelosi's 79 steny hoyer 77. jerry
brown is 80 bernie sanders is 76
and the people who are young are more
frightening i mean keith ellison and
perez so
they don't have a a second team that's
going to come in whatever you think
about the republicans they've got young
people like paul ryan and in the house
and they've got young governors marco
rubio so there's a frustration that
politically they don't know what to do
and they're angry at this guy who
doesn't fit their image of a president
he doesn't speak well he's not educated
in the way that they think he is
and their way of thinking if you and
i've tried this conversation maybe some
of you have with left-wing people who
hate trump
i said you think it's easy to make a
buck in the manhattan real estate world
crooked unions crooked politicians
crooked community organizing groups
quick environmentalists and you're going
to build a skyscraper in downtown
manhattan you've got to be a genius to
survive they don't see that
so they underestimated him in the
campaign and now as president they're
underestimating them so what is he
trying to do
[Music]
basically if you look at the agenda what
he's done it's a
1995 to 2005 agenda
that
ta the proposed tax reforms are more
like
george bush's reduction from 39 to 35
than they are ronald reagan's down to
28.
if you look at keystone and dakota
pipelines they were already approved
it was pretty a mainstream decision
hillary was all for keystone until the
election
if you look at immigration trump didn't
come up with the idea of the wall the
house republicans had voted the whole
senate approved it a third of it had
been built
listen sometimes to bill clinton in one
of his speeches from 1994 on illegal
immigration it's far to the right of
donald trump
says that and so is harry reids the
point i'm getting at is that
trump went back to the middle but the
middle it would no longer existed as we
had known it so it was considered
radical and revolutionary because they
were convinced that this trajectory
whether it was a single payer or
permanent identity politics or whatever
or lead from behind foreign policy
was set in stone
and trying to bring everybody back
was difficult
the other thing that i think frightened
them is that they were afraid that and
we're starting to see it in trump's
first hundred days is that he's not as
stupid as we think that
there is a
political paradigm
behind a lot of his uh economic policies
and i think
it's summed up by
you know
two words three percent
joe biden said it was three but maybe
four three percent growth
if he gets three percent growth due to
simplifying the tax code reducing
corporate taxes uh
deregulation in some key industry
especially epa
getting the interest rates maybe up to
one or two or three percent higher than
they are now and he can achieve three
percent growth that obama never did we
haven't had in 10 years then trump's
idea is that whatever differences you
have with one another on your religion
or race or
our
skin color color or ethnic background or
whatever animosity that you have to me
it's going to disappear
and somebody who lived through reagan's
era i can tell you
that people hated ronald reagan and he
was very unpopular in 81 and 82. i
remember there was a
congressman named reagan
and his last name was vineyard
and he ran for office reagan vineyard
and somebody went down i think it was in
southern california found this obscure
failed candidate and made his uh
campaign and printed up thousands of
copies and all over where we were
because we had an agricultural collapse
when paul volcker sort of broke
inflation the
prices went just crashed and everybody
had this sign in their thompson seedless
raisin reagan vineyard we had one reagan
vineyard reagan vineyard and everybody
said this guy cannot win
and then you turn on the tv and it was
the day after the nuclear winter i think
carl sagan told us about uh deploying
pershing missiles in germany was going
to start a nuclear war
he was bombing invading grenada it was
just he was just trumpian and then
suddenly
between and walter mondale was out of
central casting tall
handsome
liberal but not crazy liberal like
mcgovern and he was going to win
and suddenly between i think the the
dates are roughly between
1983 say in november to october 1984 the
economy grew at a blistering 7.1
and suddenly it didn't matter reagan
could have blown up the world and people
would have said at least i died rich so
people were
people switched and it was it was
miraculous for me to see all these
farmers who hated him
and all of a sudden they said they had
one guy i can remember did this he took
uh pruning chairs and sheared off the
vineyard sign and his barn and brought
it back out and said reagan with this
ragged edge on the bottom so he was no
longer reagan vineyard but it was reagan
and that's what i think has influenced
trump he feels that as a business person
that money talks
and if we're prosperous and these and so
in this way he's although he's we're
told that he's a protectionist or that
he's a mercantilist or he's pre milton
fried whatever that is if you look at
his actual economic team they're pretty
much
um
their their
idea is to grow the economy and i think
that explains a lot of what he's doing
along with
bringing people back to the center on
cultural issues abroad
it's pretty simple
if we were to take a survey of the world
on january 20th i think all of us would
say that north korea
that obama bequeathed it's not a stable
situation they had been testing they had
been threatening to blow up people
and they had been doing this predicated
on the idea that being nuts and having a
nuke or two was a good way to extort
money
and it would continue
if you looked at iran we were starting
to discover there was a side deal on
inspections there was a side deal on
hostages cash for all hostages we didn't
know about there was a side deal for
ballistic missile development and again
the premise was
that obama would or could not do
anything about it
and the united states was a played out
power if we looked at russia we were not
talking just about crimea or ukraine we
were talking about the next acquisition
in the baltic states we'd agreed that
reset
had
failed
dismantling the missile project
anti-ballistic missile in eastern europe
or making fun of mitt romney to assure
putin you'd be more flexible about the
after the election all of that stuff
had failed
and russia was in bowling china had
built these bases on the spratly islands
was on the move
it all reminded me again i don't want to
overdo this
imagery but remember jimmy carter ran on
not one soldier shall die
under my tenure i have no inordinate
fear
of communism like my opponent
and human rights will adjudicate my
foreign policy
positions
remember all that
and then i remember he sold
he got very he wanted to sell f-15s to
saudi arabia and the compromises he
would get to sell them but they wouldn't
have any bomb racks on them
so we sold them these things where they
had to uh you know sort of jerry-rigged
the bomb rocks on
so and then we found out that
after three years this therapeutic view
of human nature ended up with
china invading vietnam communist
uprisings in central america the
russians in afghanistan a revolution
iran the shah gan and and the shia
radical islam
and then reagan came in and remember he
didn't really say any things there will
be no hostages when i'm what did that
mean and that point was he was
unpredictable and he would restore
deterrence
and then when he sent missiles into
germany stationed the mayor or libya or
grenada
as i said earlier the loss of deterrence
is very dangerous and it's matched only
by the effort to recapture it so what
trump is trying to do i think via
mattis and mcmaster and that team
it's not neocon nation building
obviously it's not isolationism it's not
even just
realism it's sort of strategic
deterrence
or realist deterrence and what they're
saying is that the world is
an unstable dangerous place
because people have come to
[Music]
incorrect
conjectures about u.s power
and that's a very dangerous time in
world history whenever that happens in
other words by any empirical standard
the united states military as
cut back as it has been under obama
where we're down to below almost three
percent gdp investment if you look at
our carrier force our strategic assets
our nuclear assets
our are battle-hardened troops from
fighting in places like afghanistan
there's no military that even
approximates it there's no two
militaries together that approximate it
but deterrence is also
a frame of mind but if you believe that
that military will never be used or it
will be predictably used then you earn
the additional wage of contempt
as hitler said
i there's no greater contempt for a
military superior power that you can
push
around and people kept telling hitler
don't go into the starland don't screw
around the sarlan elections don't go in
the rhineland the french army could
crush us
and
don't go into poland because
you know britain and
france together have a bigger army they
have better tanks the shar b tank is so
much superior to mark one two or three
the new spitfire has the same
uh characteristics as the mbf 109 don't
do this and he said i saw
i saw chamberlain at munich i wanted to
step on him i wanted to stomp his
stomach and take that stupid umbrella
and hit him over the head with it
and their worms he called them people
who had been magnanimous were called
worms
and so we lost deterrence and so what
are wars wars or a laboratory experiment
to prove who was actually strong in the
first place because once you have faulty
perceptions reality is often the check
as i said earlier
today if you're in high school i went to
really rough high school
i remember a guy named armando quintana
and he'd always come on like this
i'm going to get you after and he'd do
this and he was very he was about 5-1
and there's a guy named geronimo
rodriguez who was 6-3 he was from mexico
illegally and they heard everybody five
speeches until they learned english and
jerome was the nicest guy in the world
he just said like this and then
go up and hit him and i'm going to take
you out and one day geronimo just
flattened him i mean he knocked him five
feet didn't say a word just knocked him
broke his jaw there was a big hubbub in
those days
they dismissed school everybody could
not believe it and i thought wow that's
weird and i think what geronimo was
trying to do is restore deterrence but
he had to do it in a very violent way
that was entirely unnecessary had he
just said mr quintana i would not do
that again or just tapped him once he
would have established
the rules when dean atchison said that
south korea is not within our realm of
defensive capable
assistance the north invaded just three
months later
when april gillespie said
we don't intervene with border speech
between kuwait and iraq
and then saddam invaded and we forget
that that
gestures statements
assurances to to unpredictable
aggressors that we won't react are very
very dangerous
i i had a
member of my family said when trump
is elected you'll be so scared the
world's gonna blow up i said no it'll be
the first time i rest in peace because
i've been terrified the last eight years
that some weaker power would do
something stupid on the premise that the
united states would not retaliate and
then we would get in a war which would
finally prove after many deaths and much
violence that guess what the united
states really is stronger than iran
i mean
one carrier group has more conventional
and nuclear power of course nuclear but
than the entire iranian military
it would be stupid for iran to hijack a
boat or humiliate its crew or send a
missile near a carrier and that's yet
that was what they were doing
because they felt that they had contempt
for military stronger power that would
never use it
and then you get trump in and he one of
the things about restoring deterrence is
he's capable he thinks or he tries to
project that image of saying anything to
anyone any day and doing anything
i was watching this strange media
reaction to the firing comey one of my
colleagues at hoover wrote today
well this is terrible he fired comey and
that's going to unsettle everybody
overseas and i thought no it's not
it's going to be like reagan firing the
aircraft controllers when gorbachev said
don't screw around with this guy he's
capable of anything
so i don't think people understand
because they don't live outside of that
coastal bubble but the world operates on
a tragic view of human nature rather
than this therapeutic view and the
therapeutic view is
very dangerous and
the first lord halifax i think it was in
1785 the great
jurist of british common law said when
people were trying to oppose the death
penalty for anything other than capital
crimes he said well you know we hang
horse thieves
not because he the guy stole a horse
because we don't want horses to be
stolen
and that's what deterrence is we don't
like to
do a crazy mohab bomb or bomb one
airline but that's not the purpose of it
it's to remind people with subterranean
capabilities that you shouldn't do that
because we're capable of doing something
like not announcing it
and trump would probably say if i have
an fbi director it would be
useful for him to know that i can wake
up one morning and fire him
because that creates a deterrent
attitude and you don't have that
complacency or even arrogance in hubris
that james comey because he understood
that nobody would ever question that so
a lot of the mis interpretation of what
trump is doing overseas i think can be
summed up is
it's very dangerous to try to restore
deterrence
and it's i don't know if it's a
thought out trump doctrine but i do as
someone who was a colleague of jim
mattis at hoover and and knows hr a
little bit mcmasters i think they are
trying to tell trump
that we have to find symbolic iconic
moments that will not lead to a wider
war and then we have to draw a line in a
real line not verbally but in actuality
and after a few of these incidents in
which we're going to take a lot of heat
and which are going to be very dangerous
we will re-establish deterrence and then
the world as we knew it in the post-war
order will return and this is preferable
to the alternative
if you would ask what trump would say i
would
probably say something if you ask him
i don't believe in nation-building i
don't think we can change the nature of
man the world abroad is always going to
have thugs it's like your lawn it's
always going to grow and the idea that
you're going to wave a wand in the grass
will be perfect you'll have to buy
astroturf in fantasyland because you
have to mow the lawn
and there's always going to be a saddam
hussein there's always going to be a
noriega there's always going to be a
milosevic there's always going to be a
omar
and the degree to which they can harm
innocent people depends on how well they
are deterred
and we've got to restore deterrence and
this is the way to do it where does all
this lead in conclusion as far as
the
2020 election
well
donald trump has some inconsistencies
that he ran on certain principles that
got these proverbial reagan democrats or
the white working class or the forgotten
americans or the interior americans or
the reds the blue wall americans out to
vote in a way that they didn't before i
was a teaching at hillsdale this year
and i had taught there in the 2004 12
and uh 16 elections i had never seen
signs like i saw before when i came back
to california hoover
colleagues said to me well my latest
poll he's a pollster said that trump is
going to lose by 11.
and i said i think he's going to win
michigan and they said well that's
because you rely on anecdote and you
watch tv and i have analytics i said no
it's because i rode a bike for almost 25
days and i saw
posters everywhere and at one point i
saw a person spray painting his garage
and i thought he was a vandal so i got
off my bike and i ran over and i said
you said you just
spray painted make america great who are
you did you know the owner of this he
said i am the owner
he said this is the only time i'm going
to vote i don't vote anymore i'm going
to vote for this guy and everybody you
see around here is going to vote for
this guy and i thought wow
if that would be to replicate it
throughout the blue wall states he could
win
and then when we got home i said to my
wife who teaches junior college i think
he can win he said well you know it's
very funny
i have mostly hispanic class i was
making a joke and i said i guess none of
it nobody will be voting for trump and
the girl in the front said why don't you
poll
26 to 23 trump had 23 votes of all
hispanic students in the interior of
california
these things started popping up i know
it happened to you too all the time and
we were told it was impossible
so trump appealed to working-class
people who were sick and tired of this
elite or the media whoever we call the
elite
and
that base is all that matters to him we
know now that
conservative pundits that do what i do
have no influence whatsoever
if george will writes a column i like
him a great deal i have respect for him
but if he writes a column saying trump
is the
the arch satanic figure of our time
nobody in bakersfield is going to change
his vote
it's just not going to happen if mike is
my magazine that i write for the
national if they've run on tire issues
say never trump the people of michigan
don't get up in the morning said i just
can't vote for him
it's just not going to happen
but what is going to happen is those
states have to be motivated and they
voted for him for four or five issues
and you know what they are one of them
was illegal immigration
trump was the first candidate who said i
don't have to do
amnesty light i don't have to do the
gang of eight i don't have to market the
law says you can't come in if you're
illegal
i'm not willing to deport everybody if
you're here you haven't had a criminal
record you've been here for five years
you're working maybe okay but we got
some bad hombres and that was true we do
and he basically said mexico benefits
from remittances they export the poor
rather than addressing poverty it's a
safety valve for them la raza wants to
change the demographics of the american
southwest the democratic party wants to
usher people and they do not want the
melting pot they do not want italian
americans that are assimilated that
paradigm and so
it was actually a sophisticated argument
he made
that it would be good for the
republicans in the long run
trying to outbid the democrats for
social justice to the illegal alien
community is not going to work you can't
ever outbid a democrat
but you can say i'm going to build a
wall and then you're going to
not be infused by
people who come here without education
without skills without english and
pretty soon you will be surprised how
quickly you will intermarry and
assimilate and you will follow patterns
of other ethnic groups and if your name
is scalia or alito or cuomo we won't
know what your politics are lopez
rodriguez it won't matter and that's
what he was trying to do and he's got to
stick to that and some of it was iconic
that he has to finish some kind of wall
or those people will
bowl
on trade
he introduced this idea that we've all
talked about fair trade is not free
trade
the republican establishment said
i don't know if they said it but i think
a lot of my colleagues at hoover would
believe it they would say
running up deficits is not bad
foreign competition even if it's
subsidized on their part is not
sustainable it'll weaken germany or
japan or china
and it will make our companies more
leaner and meaner
and it will lower prices at walmart for
everybody it's a great deal
and trump came along and said you say
that because you never get laid off
as i said earlier
i don't get a slip that says dear victor
hansen a person in columbia wrote a much
better column in the local paper and
he's going to be hired at the tribute
media service so they never suffered the
consequences of their own ideology and
trump then appealed i don't think he had
it thought out whether
milton friedman economics or not but
probably in the long run is not as good
for the economy but he's saying in the
short term
there are victims and we're not going to
run up these trade deficits and they're
so if they're so great let germany have
them for 10 years but let japan have
milton friedman's that'll be great for
them just try it and see what they say
and if it's so great why do they
why don't they do it
why do we do it and i don't really care
about being a leader of the free world
if youngstown ohio is destroyed
that was a very appealing message and so
he's got to he's got to deliver on that
and that means he's got to grow the
economy
and he's got to in
he's got to keep unemployment before
below 5
that's another issue on foreign
interventions he's got to be very
careful because he ran not as an
isolationist but as a pragmatic
jacksonian
we're nationalists
we pay we're whack-a-mole-less they
stick their head up we knock them down
but we don't put boots on the ground and
try to change hearts and minds i happen
to think that iraq eventually probably
worked it would have been like korea if
we hadn't precipitously pulled out
2011. sort of like eisenhower coming in
up for re-election 56 and said truman
put those guys on the 38th parallel not
me
i'm pulling them out
for a cheap campaign talk i don't think
we'd have kia and samsung today but
nevertheless that's not trump's interest
his trump is to be punitive
and yet
afghanistan's a mess if we pull out
there's going to be a lot of people
butchered there
and sort of like south vietnam circa
1975 so yet if he puts 5 000 troops and
we get involved more and more
that group of people that he promised
that he wouldn't do that are going to be
sorely disappointed same thing with some
of these trade agreements like
the pacific trade agreement or nafta
he's got to at least bring back
something to the table and though
they're very flexible but if they feel
that he's a typical politician that
promises something and then he flips
back and he joins the jeb bush
establishment he's not going to be
successful in those eight or nine states
that he has to win
because that margin is very very thin
and if he loses 150 000 votes here he's
not going to be re-elected if he does
uh what i suggested that not my idea but
if he's true to these promises to these
voters he will win
and it's going to change the republican
party if he gets reelected it already
has changed it the republican party is
now a more populist party and it's a
more empathetic party i think and i like
this idea that
nobody knows who to listen to anymore
i like the idea that writers at the wall
street journal national review or weekly
standard or comic don't are not gospel
that they're people coming in online
it's just a free-for-all there's no
hierarchy anymore i think this is very
it's much more healthy than this
geriatric cadre that runs a democratic
party or hollywood intolerant and
almost stalinist let me just finish by
the democratic party they have a choice
don't they
they
they can be empirical
and see that if hillary clinton had
appealed to the working classes and
moderated her rhetoric not talked about
irredeemables not
sort of sold herself out to the identity
politics movement she probably would not
have lost too many of her base and she
would have gained some and she probably
she did win three million plus voters
but margin she probably would have come
close and only the one or two states she
needed to do and she probably would have
won
any same person would see that would be
the anecdote so what you would not want
to do is
nominate somebody like keith ellison or
perez tomper as the dnc chairman
or you would not want to continue this
call it the resistance as if these
people are french
fighters out in the maki trying to
ambush the waffen ss it's not a good
image it's it's like 1968 when
the democratic party came within three
tenths of a percentage point of beating
a very unpopular more unpopular than
trump richard nixon
and they were killed because george
wallace took 13 percent of the vote
which translated in the loss of five
southern states to wallace
five to nixon that humphrey would have
won and then you add in the left-wing
lunacy at the chicago
convention and they blew that election
and then the the anecdote was obviously
to tell somebody like
humphrey a muskie or somebody
don't get caught with an anti-war fringe
group
and make sure that wallace doesn't don't
shoot him but make sure that he doesn't
run in 72 which he did and he was shot
and he was not a successful candidate
but try to get that working class and
what did they do
they said 71 voters act gave seven 18
year olds the right to vote this is the
sort of new progressive movement we're
going to get
george mcgovern and win it was the
largest third largest landslide in
american electoral history because they
read the la they doubled down on failure
and it took them two elections to
realize
that nobody gets nominated who wins
after jfk
between jfk and barack obama were both
different candidates
nobody could win unless they had a
southern accent
nominate a guy like al gore wins a
popular vote bill clinton wins the
president jimmy carter wins and lbj you
nominate somebody like mondale or
dukakis or kerry
they don't win
because people didn't trust the
democratic party on social issues and
they wanted some often
authentic conservative they thought with
a southern accent so that was sort of
the remedy and obama brought this new
paradigm it's not as i said not
transferable so they have a choice to
make if you don't want to see them
elected
then i hope you're very happy that
stephen colbert and bill meyer are using
mar are using this atrocious language
that we see who's running the dnc or
pretty much they can't say a speech
without using a profanity
and hollywood's enlisted madonna
ashley judd all of these people are
building this image that we saw in 72
and it leads nowhere but to oblivion
and so trump has been given a great gift
in the nature of his opposition so
basically it's if trump can please his
base
and grow the economy at three percent
and avoid a major war by restoring
deterrence he's going to win
and if the democratic party
if he doesn't he's still going to win if
the democratic party goes the mcgovern
route thank you very much if you have
any questions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is howard seger mark
about 50 years ago nikita khrushchev
came to the united nations in a very
famous news clip he took his shoe off
and pounded the table
one interpretation of that
was that khrushchev wanted to show that
he was crazy enough to possibly use
nukes
is it possible
that
mr trump's sometimes irrational tweets
have the same kind of effect on our
international enemies
no i think it's not only possible it's
almost guaranteed
if you read
it is painful but read the art of the
deal or the order that come back or make
an american agree and that you ask for
twice as much as you expect you get 51
that's a great deal
you act crazy so you unnerve your
opponent we've always known and henry
kissinger wrote that in his book about
deterrence that acting unpredictable was
of advantage remember in the yom kippur
war nixon said now you go over and tell
the russians that i'm crazy i'm a mad
bomber and i'm going to put us on stage
three alert and then you're the sober
and judicious voice that has to calm me
down and you'll have a lot more success
nixon said that at work
and so i think that's sort of what
i don't think they want to broadcast
that but i when i see
mcmaster on sunday evening tv or sunday
morning i see mattis it's almost like
they're telling the world
you guys don't know what we have to put
up with we're dealing with a guy he
wants to get out of nato he wants to
nuke pyongyang he'll do anything but
you've got to deal with us help me out
and then you get you almost get the
impression that they go into a room with
trump and trump said well how did it go
you guys
you know
and so
the danger of that is that
our adversaries are brilliant people and
they're trying to say trump and those
guys are in that school and this is a
script of the apprentice and don't fall
for it so we have to at some point
deliver
and so that's a danger that we'll have
in restore but i think you're absolutely
right
yes thanks for doing this
thank you
professor thank you very much michael
maybach um
in the case of north korea yes there's
for
lots of us it seems like it's an
impossible situation because their their
troops are so close to seoul yes and so
even though he sends
the sixth fleet etc
at some point
um
does that become a real problem for him
to
to use leverage in the united states
well it's a very tricky
but i i don't think any situation
throughout history is impossible there's
always an answer
and north korea realizes that when
you're when you act crazy and you have
nothing to lose and you have a few nukes
then that results in
bribery dango they get they've got
billions of dollars and iran is
following the same script pakistan does
the same thing
and that when you're sober and judicious
like israel or france you get nothing
with nukes so we all understand the game
they're playing the question is can we
find a way to mitigate it without
leading to the loss of soul
and first thing we have to do is get on
board with our allies we have to get
japan and taiwan and australia and south
korea philippines all on the same page
so i i don't object to him having the
philippine president there who's kind of
thuggish anymore i mean he's not as
sluggish as the iran president that we
dealt with so you got to get on the same
page you can't have south korea
freelancing and saying to the north
these these mean americans are pushing
us they can't be doing that and they're
doing that now
with this new president the second thing
is that we do have
as trump has
showed trump has been criticized because
like a madman he says
china is rigging the currency china's
running up debts china's cheating on
patents and then he's quietly saying now
if you're willing to
help us pressure them
cut off their coal imports or what then
we're going to drop all that
well
in trump's mind if they help on north
korea then we're back where we started
economic no worse off but we're a lot
better off with north korea so he's
trying to
and that's the only country that can
pressure them
because they have a billion people and i
don't think north korea thinks they're
going to do much damage to china
so north china has been playing a
a dirty game it's sort of like having a
pit bull with a leash and every once in
a while they said where's my leash at my
pit bull's missing and they know it goes
right into your yard and bites you i had
a neighbor kind of like that he'd always
say i don't know where my pet bulls are
and they always every time i got an
argument they ended up in my yard biting
me so that's what north korea does and
we have to say you can't do that anymore
and if you do it you're going to say
face severe economic ramifications then
we have a final and unsavory card
and i think that donald rumsfeld played
it once in 2006 we we tell
china
and north korea the world is a very
dangerous place in your neighborhood
mexico is not nuclear canada is not
nuclear we have two oceans i know that's
nuclear war but we give it we have some
preparatory time
but you've got nuclear pakistan you've
got nuclear russia you've got nuclear
india you've got american nuclear assets
you've got
a new nuclear iran right do you really
want a nuclear japan
taiwan and south korea and australia
around you because you're headed that
way
because they're going to need deterrence
and our clients nuclear
weapons will work like kias or toyotas
they won't blow up in the launching pad
like yours
so you broke the agreement that your
client would not go nuclear and we're
going to break ours and they can go
nuclear if they wish to
that's that's about all we have
um and we i hate to say if you're gonna
insist on sanctions with north korea and
then people are eating grass you can't
be like the clinton administration oh my
god they're eating grass
well they have to eat grass for the
sanctions to work i hate to say it but
it's better than people getting nuked
so
we have these these limited but
necessary but necessary and valuable
options i think they're all being played
right now
and i hope they work
uh thanks and thank you for your speech
um i was just wondering you were talking
earlier about 2016 and how a lot of
democrats really didn't think that trump
could win at all and in fact the media
was constantly talking about that i also
noticed that they did that in 2012 with
romney and i was very suspicious of that
because i never quite understood why
romney was so far in the hole that he
couldn't possibly win it's one thing to
say he's the underdog it's another thing
to say he can't win and they did it the
same thing
with trump and i'm wondering do you
think that it's possible this is just a
strategy they're going to keep trying to
use
well obviously it's of some utility yes
because then they tell your voters
there's no reason to go out and vote
they're sort of like the san francisco
giants in a losing year why would you
want to go out they're not going to win
why would you want to go watch them
don't participate in the losing cause so
yes i think that was a lot of it
but also they believed after eight years
of this sort of yuppie identity politics
that this was the trajectory where
the health care
act was a prelude to the single payer
black lives matter was a prelude to gay
marriage to
transgendered restrooms to who know what
next no gender identification on your
like driver's life everything was a
logical incremental step to a
progressive paradise and it was faded it
was hegelian
it was faded and that's what they
believed
and they thought that
the white working class was
self-destructive perhaps suicidal maybe
of short longevity
we know that and doomed
and so they were going to make the
necessary political adjustments and they
were going to have i think 50 years some
of people wrote it and they they
miscalculated terribly miscalculated
because they didn't understand the
electoral college they didn't understand
that not everybody believes that rate
your race is your destiny there's a
growing number of people
in my family
to take one example of a mixed race and
they don't identify with any race
and people want to be americans
and so the identity politics is not
necessarily our our destiny and they
they misinterpret a lot of things they
all but give them credit they they won
by three million votes so they almost
won the electoral college
it was about 250 000 brave americans
that said i've had enough and went out
and voted for the first time and they
voted against hillary
and you got to give donald trump credit
because
for someone who had no political it's
most it's the most unique phenomenon in
american electoral history somebody with
no political experience first president
that neither had
political office holding or military
office a rank
won the presidency and before bannon and
before conway and before all of his
strategists came on
he crafted that strategy
you can say that he he just made it up
but he he crafted a strategy that none
of his gifted republican uh
con contendents and opponents
actualized it was it was quite brilliant
what he did
i was telling a group today i keep
saying because i've talked to a group i
don't want to repeat myself if you're in
the audience but
i have a wife who's um
i would say
middle of the road
and
she said to me
you got to come in here this man is i'm
going to vote for donald trump
i said why
and he said come and look and what she
was referring to was
jorge ramos a univision
who's a multi-millionaire fled to the
safety of the united states cashed in
big lives in a gated community british
kids in
private schools daughters working for
hillary clinton and says that trump is a
racist in our country was racist for
voting for him tried to crash that press
conference interrupted a number of times
and then trump she said donald trump
deported jorge ramos from espresso he
said get out of here
nobody's ever done that to that guy
doesn't he know that's gonna what
they're gonna do to him i said he
doesn't care
and she goes no he doesn't care does he
i'm gonna vote for him
and i think a lot of people had that
visceral i don't know if that's a
paradigm to governance but it surely
electrified people when he did that or
he pointed up and said look at those
media people
they're all liars and i thought
and you know i thought well i'm going to
read tomorrow this
wrinkled frown opera that this is a
threat to
to our republic but you know when glenn
thrush writes
to john podesta and says i'm a hack
we want to proofread my article or
daniel milbank says i'm going to attack
trump tomorrow can you guys give me some
free research
that's what they are
that's what they are or the new york
times says you can't be disinterested
anymore because trump is unique and
therefore you have to be out of the
sword so he's crude yeah but he always
hits the essence of it
i have no idea whether it's sustainable
or not
okay so i've been watching the the media
reaction
with a certain amount of amusement
because i have to tell you it's like
dinner and a show every night
and i'm kind of curious
there's an awful lot of people like me i
just quit watching the news
i get my news in other ways i get my
news through online blogs i find other
things i find other ways to do it where
do you see this going i mean do you
think i think what you're referring to i
wrote an article once called the
monastery of the mind where we've all
retreated to mental monasteries and i
mentioned this earlier i used to watch
espn i like sports but i don't like to
have a jock lecture me i'm off politics
it was an ignoramus so i just tuned out
the whole thing out and then i noticed
there must have been a lot of us because
espn's almost broke
and then i noticed that
about three years ago i went to a movie
i didn't know what it was i was shopping
i just thought well it's going to be
either a person a diversity person is
going to be attacking an evil
corporation or there's going to be evil
people with south african or southern
accents and sure enough it was or it's
going to be a remake of a great movie
and it's going to be a terrible remake
so that
they have no i mean i just watched a
great movie this magnificent seven and i
went and watched the remake and it was
diverse it was horrible so i thought to
myself
i'm not gonna go to movies anymore and i
quit doing it and i noticed that
everybody's quit doing it and i don't
mean everybody but half the population i
think that's what's happening that
people are psychologically
disengaging
there was a word in classical greek
called safrasune and meant not just
prudence but
prudence in the sense that you didn't
want to participate anymore in the arena
of a radical athenian democracy and a
guy wrote a book called the quiet
athenian
it's about people who just sort of
disengaged from athens because they
thought they had nothing to offer and
they were not appreciated
and in california i see them everywhere
as one person just told me i don't mind
paying 13
and still getting the 46 ranked schools
and 49th and roads but i don't like it
when i'm called greedy
and avaricious and selfish for paying 13
so i think a lot of us have disengaged
from the media and we're looking for
outlets or
or alternative news
and i think it's healthier again i think
this chaos is wonderful
and i i'm a dropout like you of a lot of
things i don't watch
the super bowl anymore
if there's a concert on tv 18 and it's
madonna any popular entertainment i turn
it off i went i think i learned about
this i went to a service station on
pacheco pass when i was going back from
stanford home and a rapper
pulled up next to me and he had
this typical rap kill the [ __ ] shoot
the pig really loud and i was
listening i thought i'm not going to
take this i'm 63 years old so i had
two songs i had a truck and it took me a
while so i had
that famous folk song i think
i don't know who wrote it
but it was called the colorado trail
it's a cowboy song and i turned that on
as loud as i could
and then i turned
the next channel was joan baez
the pleasures of love it's a famous
frank french ballot and i played that as
loud as guy and so the guy stalked over
to me he said wow man that's pretty good
music
and so i said well you know we've all
been listening to your stuff and you
never hear our stuff
and so you never know what you're going
to expect but i i don't think we have to
take it anymore
we don't have monasteries anymore but we
have them in our mind
i go to a
walmart where everybody is basically
from mexico they're wonderful people
most of them are illegal but you i see
things in there you'll never believe
five or six ebt cards
everything this stuff this is going to
sound a liberal i shouldn't say it on
tape but i was in there yesterday and
there was a
an asian person who was there
and he was watching everybody's speaking
in spanish everything and he he was very
educated and he said to me dr livingston
i presume and i thought what does that
mean
he was asian and what he was saying is
that
i'm asian
you're white there's mexican-american
people like us but we don't have to
accept the fact that everybody comes the
united states and has ebt cards and does
not learn the language and is rude and
line and just because it's a diversity
issue we're not supposed to say anything
this person was a third generation
japanese so i think people are saying
you know what i don't have to apologize
what what propelled trump was the total
absence of any guilt
he didn't apologize for being wealthy he
didn't apologize for being crude
a very prominent editor called me and
said trump is going to pull out and
access hollywood because they released
today and we need to get on board i said
he's not going to pull out it was crude
he shouldn't have done it but he's not
going to he's not the apologetic type
maybe sometimes he should but i think it
was a it was a shout and said we're not
going to apologize anymore we have
nothing to apologize for
and
deterrence is a funny thing where i live
i have a lot of most of my friends are
mexican-american and we have canteens up
and down our avenue and they all have
mexican flags
two weeks after the election
i american flag
california flag at everyone
i go to walmart parking lot my car's
been hit by people that don't have
licenses came from mexico very hard
working
but they hit the car and they leave
a woman
hit my bumper
ready to leave i look at her she rolls
down the window and said please don't
tell donald trump i don't want to go
back to mexico
i'm serious
so the left would say that that's a sign
of the climate of fear and anxiety in
the lives that he's ruining
a skeptic would say he'd created
deterrence
so i think it it's
i think it's still healthy i know there
can be darker channels we could go to
but i think people have to learn
that the guy you see
on msnbc or the op-ed that you read in
the washington post or that professor on
youtube is not representative of most
people
and he look he's actually ridiculous
he's an emperor without any clothes all
you have to do is shout and that's what
they did in that election